ok ok ok salut c'est monsieur drogue
j'ai vu beaucoup de vidéos sur le
mythique de s avant de faire une vidéo
avant de vous parler d'un smartphone
bien évidemment je prends un peu en main
je regarde comment il marche mais
surtout je regarde beaucoup ce que dit
un peu tout le monde
voilà tout le monde pour faire une
opinion non pas pour influencer mon test
ou modifier ma façon on n'a pas le temps
de voir les choses mais simplement pour
vraiment vraiment être au fait de ce qui
se dit sur un produit
je le fais en règle générale avant de
khartoum et est hélas aujourd'hui je
vous parlais ce produit dans le mini
faisait de chiots j'étais payé pas très
longtemps le minix deux déjà fait une
vidéo pour vous en parler
et là je me suis dit pourquoi pas été
fait cet aveu mx2 est ce parce que sur
le papier en tout cas je trouve vraiment
intéressant il a un design qui tranche
avec tous autant trouver cette année en
il va plus loin il va bousculer les
codes et au final c'est un modèle qui
avait plutôt cool
alors est-ce que ce minix de s et bien
oui ou non il ya beaucoup d'avis qu'il
dise effectivement si les knicks de s
est décevant n'est pas le smartphone
qu'on attendait par shiomi dans cette
gamme de prix on est un peu déçu il y a
à contrario des avis qui disent ce
smartphone est bon ce smartphone est
bien il ya de bons résultats et un
hacker dit ce smartphone est excellent
alors au final
au milieu de tout ça mais la place du
consommateur l'agglo dit alors attendez
j'ai regardé une vidéo puis une autre
puis une autre au final ce chiot me fait
pas du tout l'unanimité est ce que c'est
un excellent smartphone f que c'est une
boule shit
est-ce qu'il faut l'acheter oui ou non
c'est très compliqué à savoir donc moi
ce que je vais faire du vous donner mon
avis non influencés par ce que j'ai vu
on va regarder déjà qu'elles ont la
boîte voir si elle est cool
oui ou non on va regarder la puissance
la performance l'autonomie la photo la
vidéo l'audio tout ça on va le regarder
pour au final savoir est-ce que ce chien
aux milices de s est un excellent
smartphone oui
j'aime beaucoup quand ça commence comme
ça parce que effectivement un peu zeit
il ya un peu devient un peu d'enjeu
première chose on va l'ouvrir
moi ce que j'aime bien déjà sur la boîte
c'est que ça change par rapport aux
différents packaging qu'on peut
retrouver chez xiaomi notamment sur les
produits d'entrée de gamme ça c'est si
ça c'est un produit d'entrée de gamme de
chez home y voyez ça change vraiment on
n'a pas assez de couleur on n'a pas ce
petit format compact là quelque chose de
beaucoup plus sympa on passe on va
maintenant regarder à l'intérieur
lorsqu'on lourd ça c'est un effet waouh
non pas sur le produit mais son
packaging
vous avez tout d'abord un petit message
de laâyoune qui est le fondateur de
xiaomi qui vous met un petit message
sympathique toujours plein de valeurs
pour expliquer un peu
l'adn est l'essence de ce produit c'est
ça qui est génial pour ce genre de
produit c'est le fait d'avoir
différentes durée d'ouverture donc là on
a ce petit message de bienvenue et là
vous arrivez bénin le produit mx ds sur
votre gauche sur votre droite vous avez
votre petit câble usb tissée vers usb
ici vous avez votre adaptateur secteur
et là nous avons le mime x2 s vient par
là mon petit 1 il ya tout qui lie
reproduit très joli on va le regarder en
détail dans quelques instants
on continue de voir ce que dans cette
boîte donc beaucoup up j'enlève ça un
autre degré d'ouverture avec la petite
languette qui vient là dans lequel nous
avons à cool
alors ça c'est joli voyez super bien
intégré très bien fait votre petite
pique pour venir votre tiroir de cap
cime
vous avez ici un adaptateur usb type
s'est prise jack
parce que sur la bête vous n'avez
absolument aucune prise jack
après apple maxxium ici mais sur son
modèle haut de gamme c'est dommage
à l'intérieur nous avons quoi toujours
un petit mot sympathique
il ya un côté très premium dans cette
doc une petite coque pour venir
positionner sur votre smartphone l'heure
est maintenant venue de regarder ce
fameux smartphone petite languette qui
vient protéger vos capteurs votre
appareil photo
là ça vous indique qu'à du nfc double
tiroirs carte sim la voilà la bête
design simple sobre efficace si c'est le
modèle noir il existe également un
modèle blanc vous avez un dos en
céramique incurvé il vous permet de la
recharge par induction xiaomi à
privilégier
nick là dessus plutôt que le ver priori
selon re ça serait plus solide néanmoins
conséquent même de les protéger
d'ailleurs en talons protection on va
essayer celle qui fournit à l'intérieur
c'est pas vilain et puis surtout ça a le
mérite d'être dans la boîte et inclure
votre produit pour ça c'est plutôt cool
que j'aime là dessus c'est cet écran
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
différent par rapport à se retrouver
ailleurs sur le marché c'est à dire que
déjà d'une vous avez pas dans coche en
haut ça change je vais pas dire que
c'est mieux que c'est moins bien mais
juste que c'est différent que ça change
et ça pour le coup c'est vraiment
intéressant quasiment pas de bord si
vous regardez bien sur les côtés sur le
haut il n'y a quasiment pas de bord et
ça aussi je dois reconnaître que c'est
vraiment un point positif points entre
guillemets un peu négatif mais qui
réellement dans les pins
c'est la grande bordure en bas pourquoi
vous avez une grande bordure en bas
juste parce que vous avez si votre
appareil photo et qu'à un moment il faut
bien connecté votre écran à quelque
chose donc les connecteurs se trouve sur
le bas c'est différent ça change par
rapport aux smartphones vous avez des
encoches euros et des grandes mort sur
le bas surtout c'est pas mal on a un peu
plus de place utile c'est vraiment
pratique
je trouve un peu épais par rapport à ce
qu'on peut trouver sur notre modèle mais
globalement c'est du point de chipotage
donc c'est franchement pas grand chose à
l'arrière il est assez élégant la
céramique est sympa il ya quand même
quelques traces de doigts de toute façon
sur les smartphones avec des dos en
verre ou du doigt en céramique les
traces de doigts vous les aurez mis à
part avoir des d'eau en plastique où
effectivement l'approprier pas trace de
doigt ce typologie de produits
c'est plutôt normal vous avez un écran
ip slcd de 5.99 pouces de diagonale un
format 18/9 une résolution de 2160 parmi
80 fixe elle séduit fhd plus à 403 paix
pays la gamme de couleurs c'est du dci
p3 pinch to zoom up paf je vois c'est
que j'ai effectivement que toute petite
bordure sur le côté c'est plutôt pas mal
je retrouve ici cette grosse bordure à
droite forcément où j'ai mon capteur
photo mais qui globalement ne me dérange
pas j'en profite c'est quand même pas
mal je vais renier un peu dans l'image
mais ça c'est un grand classique
aujourd'hui par contre ici j'ai pas d'un
coach qui viennent embêter
donc je profite vraiment de ma vidéo
complète et ça c'est tout pas mal ce qui
est plutôt bien sur ce modèle si vous
pouvez régler les contrastes et la
couleur pouvait mettre des couleurs un
peu plus chocs vont permettre d'éliminer
la lumière
notamment pour éviter une fatigue
oculaire qui est pas mal de possibilités
et sa folk ou de reconnaître que c'est
top c'est un smartphone qui acceptent de
la recharge sans fil grâce à son dos en
céramique avec la charge qui sans fil
par contre là falloir vous acheter un
chargeur en plus parce qu'elle ne sera
pas inclus dedans au niveau autonomie
vous avez une batterie de 3400
milliampères heures l'autonomie est
plutôt correct vous pouvez tenir une
journée ça les premiers sur une fois de
plus de notre utilisation si vous
utiliser à fond les jeux si vous êtes
tout le temps dessus et la lumière trop
regarder ce qui se passe
forcément il va se décharger beaucoup
plus rapidement si par contre vous
l'utilisez de temps en temps pour garder
vos e-mails l'aller sur vos réseaux
sociaux utilisés quelques applications
vous pouvez tenir une journée sans aucun
problème à noter qu en une heure vous
l'avez quasiment chargées à 100 % 80 %
donc c'est plutôt pas mal
vous pouvez mettre soi une soit deux
cartes sim directement dedans ici pas
d'expansion carte microsd donc vous avez
forcément rester soit en 64 giga 68 giga
de stockage côté pas formé entre autres
martin dragonne 845 qui aujourd'hui le
processeur le plus puissant de chez
qualcomm si giga de ram je vous ai dit
en tout cas je sais soit 64 soit 128
giga c'est une machine qui fonctionne
plutôt bien et vous avez le plus
graphique c'est une adreno 630 qu en
est-il de l'appareil photo de ce mix de
s vous avez un double module photo à
l'arrière à la verticale deux fois 12
mégapixels le premier maître une
lentille grand angle avec une
stabilisation optique sur quatre axes
avec une ouverture de f 1.8
le deuxième est rude objectif de longues
focales également 12 mégapixels est une
ouverture de f 2.4
les objectifs sont des sonneries mx360 3
normalement la qualité d'eau rendez vous
c'est ce qu'on va les voir tout de suite
à l'extérieur ce mx 2 usa à l'arrière
tout l'objectif qui va vraiment vous
servir pour le mode portrait pour avoir
vraiment un flou d'arrière-plan quelque
chose qui se détache complètement mais
surtout est ce qui est pas possible de
ce produit c'est l'autofocus dualpix
elle qui l'a vraiment venir faire le
point quelque chose de très précis et
surtout à ce que j'apprécie énormément
c'est la stabilisation optique cent
quatre axes ça c'est un régal en vidéo
vous pouvez filmer en 4k en 1080p et en
720p à 30 images par seconde il ya
également du slow motion en 720p et en
1080p à 240 images par seconde
l'incident noir dans le noir c'est un
toutes les lumières de speedy absolument
qu'une lien juste une petite source de
lumière à travers des volets autant vous
dire que franchement c'est pas terrible
terrible et malgré tout ça fonctionne
alors effectivement il ya beaucoup de
bruit et images pas extraordinaire si
normal de l'autre
des concerts des vidéos dans le noir je
vous rappelle que les gammes sur un
smartphone qui coûte entre 500 à 600
euros
on va pas lui demander la lune mais le
rendu malgré tout et quand même correct
collective de caméras telle fille c'est
vraiment une question intéressante parce
que c'est vraiment le parti pris de chez
omidvar poser une petite caméra en bas
ici regarder s'avoue le marc hottiger
phone c'est à dire que très clairement
si on me prend le parti de se dire on
met une caméra de celle fille en bas et
on avertit l'utilisateur en lisant de
retourner son smartphone au moins offert
un selphy je dois reconnaître que dans
l'idée c'est un peu osé mais c'est
vraiment bizarre
d'ailleurs vous êtes l'agglo smartphone
hop vous voulez prendre une photo et
vous devez forcément leur tournée s'est
découvert des selles fille un peu rapide
c'est pascal mieux pas effectivement
retourne au smartphone ça va assez vite
mais sans secousses assez bizarre en
termes d' usage
après ça reconnaît tout de suite
extrêmement bien mon visage d'autant
plus si les applications qu'ils prennent
pas de but tout ça en charge et sache si
on me l'avait pas forcément anticipé
je vous prends l'exemple de snapshot par
exemple ça va faire des photos est à
anvers puis donc partager des photos de
moi
la tête à l'envers à moins de faire une
photo avec l'appareil photo et ensuite
de l'impertinence nachat ce qui fait que
je porte à bénéficier des fictions les
snapshots sinon c'est globalement pas
terrible ça ça vaut pour pas mal
d'applications externes
donc ça c'est vraiment le point de
regretter smartphones à côté de ça la
vidéo fonctionne plutôt bien ce qui est
très bizarre aussi c'est à dire comme ça
et de faire des vidéos si vous oubliez
de le bouger dans vous allez forcément
avec votre main ici bloquer un petit peu
et avoir votre doigt qui apparaît ça va
bloquer le capteur avant pour pas
oublier de le retourner c'est très très
bizarre mais bon après ça vous fait une
vidéo qui est pas dégueu n'oubliez pas
qu'on a qu'une caméra de 5 mégapixels à
l'avant c'est parce qu'elle mieux même
si en photo on peut avoir un effet boké
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle donc
un effet boké logiciel contrairement à
l'effet boké du double capteur arrière
qui a en effet bloqué plus naturelle qui
fait grâce aux objectifs ça fonctionne
c'est pas horrible c'est pas non plus
quelle mieux mais une fois de plus
chasse par sua dès que placer ce capteur
photo ici en bas c'est quand même très
particulier
côté photo du pape aux lettres que je
suis franchement surpris j'ai lu un peu
tout et son contraire des avis plutôt
positif des critiques au contraire assez
négatives et je dois reconnaître que je
suis vraiment mais vraiment très surpris
je trouve que ça fonctionne extrêmement
bien tôt focus fonctionne très bien les
couleurs sont très bien rendus
les contours sont très nettes le rendu
est vraiment bien j'ai vraiment
satisfait du mix de s sur les photos sur
le capteur principal le mode portrait
également fonctionne très bien vous avez
des contours qui sont très bien dessiné
un vrai flou d'arrière plan
quelque chose qui est vraiment bien
alors j'ai testé en faible luminosité
c'est alain petit paul bât blesse
une fois qu'ils sont différents
smartphones coûte entre 500 à 600 euros
on va pas non plus lui demander d'abord
un rendu professionnel comme sur un
appareil photo sur un reflex néanmoins
je trouve qu'il s'en sort plutôt pas mal
il ya effectivement beaucoup de bruit
car ajouté c'est normal c'est normal
d'heure vous avez pas vu hier un
appareil photo il ya john lumière
veulent capter la lumière est là
beaucoup moins les deux oui c'est
logique tant reproché dans moi c'est les
photos avec le deuxième objectif
d'ailleurs vous passez sur le zoom x 2
s'est tout de suite pas terrible j'ai
beau essayer de chercher et de le faire
le point ce n'est pas là c'est vraiment
les points de regrets sur le deuxième
capteur os x deux cépages et c'est
franchement pas terrible mais sur le
capteur principal ça marche
merveilleusement bien les photos sans
capteur de celles ci fonctionnent
également ce correct on va pas se mentir
c'est pas non plus extraordinaire c'est
pas aussi bien que ce que peut avoir à
l'arrière ce capteur photo principale
mais ça fonctionne ça fait franchement
les jeunes et le das quand l'été du lot
parce qu'on parle jamais du das le das
c'est le débit d'absorption spécifique
pour les téléphones mobiles
lorsque vous le posez à l'oreille il un
das qui est de 0 5 142 watts par
kilogramme faut savoir quelles limites
elle est de 2 à 2 serait même
relativement fort 0,52 watts par
kilogramme
ça fonctionne et c'est aux smartphones
qui a du bluetooth 5.0 et qui a surtout
le grand désavantage de ne pas avoir de
prise directe alors je sais que la prise
jack
ça n'intéresse pas tout le monde
néanmoins moi je suis toujours
possesseurs de ce genre d'appareil
je suis toujours apprécié au casque
bluetooth j'envisage pas pour l'instant
de passer donc vous avez un petit
adaptateur alors ça c'est fort
sympathique parce que vous le branchez
et ça vous permet de brancher votre
casque dedans moment casque il est lourd
ça tire dessus et à la loupe à sa
terrible il fait que vous balader avec
votre casque voilà vous avez ça en plus
alors c'est bien si vous le posez sur
enduro si vous le posez quelque part et
que vous en mettez pas à les déplacer
si vous vous baladez dans la rue avec ce
genre d'accessoire ça rajoute s'assurera
joue je connais pas terrible et ça c'est
vraiment dommage médaillon sujet qu'en
est-il de l'audio on va tester on a un
seul haut-parleur c'est du haut parleur
mono
le 2 ça fonctionne ya du son on n'a pas
d'eau parleurs stéréo mais pour écouter
de la musique sans vos smartphones ça va
très bien maintenant qu'en est il du
côté du casque
bon ça fonctionne c'est pas énorme
c'est pas le truc qui vous envoie le
plus de sens qui crache à fond j'ai pas
fait la limite a effectivement vous avez
un message dallaire faisant attention
vous allez vous abîmer les oreilles
d'ailleurs vous dis attention attention
également à vous ne poussez pas le son
trop fort ça va il ya du sont lâchés
dans un milieu très calme j'imagine que
dans un milieu où il ya du bruit à
l'extérieur ça risque d'être un petit
peu limite je vous conseille pour ça de
prendre un casque actifs qui va vraiment
vont couper du son extérieur et qui vous
évitera que celle sont à fond sur ce
type de casque ça c'est vraiment un
conseil du peu de villes où elles sont
nées sur un android et 8.0 avec un mi-8
9.5 ça fonctionne
ce qui pourra perturber certains de
personnes c'est qu'effectivement ici il
n'ya pas de tiroirs d'applications
notamment pour tous les grands fans je
dirais d'android vous pouvez aller le
chercher il y en a pas cette surcouche
mois elle ne me dérange absolument pas
l'un pas vraiment d'une question de goût
personnel savoir si ce genre de choses
vous plaît oui ou non
c'est donc l'heure du bilan final au
final est-ce que ce chien au mythe ni
mx2 s est intéressant oui ou non est ce
que vous pouvez vous positionner dessus
c'est un produit qui est disponible en
64 giga à 499 90 euros 500 euros et en
128 giga à 600 euros 199 90 par le
processeur comme dragon 845 fonctionne
ici double objectif avec des sony ça
fonctionne c'est pas mal c'est pas idéal
je vous le dit tout à l'heure sur
l'appareil photo lorsque vous passez en
zoom x 2 ses moyens faible luminosité
ça fonctionne pas non plus
extraordinaire mais une fois de plus on
est sur un smartphone donc il faut
rester réaliste papa sans en avoir des
choses qui font des merveilles sur un
smartphone mais je vous le dis pour de
la photo classique
à l'arrière c'est top l'autofocus
dualpix elle fonctionne extrêmement bien
ce que je regrette vraiment sur cet
appareil moi c'est vraiment la caméra à
l'avant voulait faire une photo vous
devez leur tournée pour vous prendre en
photo je couds c'est un petit peu un non
sens parce que ça rajoute un geste
supplémentaire alors de smartphones
n'ont pas si ça ça ne vous dérange pas
c'est un smartphone qui est plutôt pas
mal
je regrette néanmoins effectivement
comme vous lisez sur des applications
tierces comme snatch a comme instagram
se soit pas du tout adaptable à le
retourner une fois de plus j'imagine pas
que ce nachat instagram ou les autres
développé spécialement cette
fonctionnalité pour faire plaisir à
chaud me pour le modèle mx2 mais ses
mixes ça c'est un petit peu le point un
peu bizarre malgré tout ça le mérite
d'être un appareil qui est quand même
assez atypique pad encoche pour le coût
des facteurs de l'encoche sont très
contents donc ça se corse c'est vraiment
le point positif quelque chose de
vraiment atypique donc est ce que vous
devez acheter ce smartphone est ce que
vous pouvez en tout cas vous positionner
dessus de ça dépend ça dépend de vous
c'est le fait qu'ils pas d'encoches vous
trouvé ça génial
au contraire si vous avez l'encoche et
bloqué un petit peu dessus si cette
caméra en bas vous bloque pas vous
pouvez y aller l'appareil photo qui est
top sur le capteur principal avec le
duel pixels ça fonctionne à merveille
maintenant ça en bas je me répète mais
c'est très bizarre
en termes de prix il est positionné mais
par rapport aux moines +6 il est quand
même un petit peu cher mais toujours une
fête plus des grandes lignes mais quand
je dis ça le watt pulsé un écran oled de
6,28 pouces là vous avez un écran de
quasiment 6 pouces séduit ps une dalle
lcd
elle fonctionne pour cela fonctionne
très bien le couleurs sont que des
contrastes fonctionne nous en mettre
plus de contraste et des couleurs
beaucoup plus éclatante sur une dalle
oled pour voir vous êtes sensiblement
sur le même prix c'est un peu le point
de regret ce que j'aime en plus on monte
plus 6,4 sur ce produit
c'est l'adage chassez la recharge rapide
ou en un clin d'oeil de les recharger
votre smartphone en plus de ça ça votre
puis 6 vous allez aussi lui giga de ram
bon voilà tout ça à mettre un petit peu
dans la balance je pense qu'il va
réellement orienter votre choix au final
ce sont des goûts personnels
une question d'encoches une question
design une question d'affinités avec la
marque
je trouve que c'est un bon smartphone si
vous vous y retrouver dans tout ce que
je vous ai décrites il est petit bémol
que je mets en avant pour cause pas de
problème vous pouvez y aller vous serez
pas déçus d'autant plus que si au mythe
arrive en france et pas très longtemps
ils gèrent leur sav directement ça c'est
plutôt top d'ailleurs si ce projet vous
intéresse je vous ai mis des liens dans
la description on trouvait au meilleur
tarif dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter par ses mimiques de est
est ce que vous l'avez est ce que vous
l'avez déjà acheté parce que c'est un
produit qui est déjà sorti sur le marché
si vous l'avez dites moi ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que vous en êtes content
est ce que ces petites caméras là vous
pose problème est ce que vous allez
satisfait si vous envisagez de l'acheter
dites moi un petit peu les
interrogations que vous avez vous
remarqué tout sans commentaire on va
essayer d'en discuter ensemble et de
faire avancer un peu le débat merci
à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo comme
d'habitude je vais la laisser des jolies
pousse à vous abonner va se parler
toujours plus de teck surprise qui
arrivent il ya plein de nouveautés plein
de tests
donc on reste connectés merci à vous et
à très bientôt d'ici là soyez sages et
n'oubliez pas vous embrasse tous les
meilleurs temps
[Musique]